klar die pandemie ist noch nicht
wirklich vorbei aber wir haben keinen
bock mehr drauf
es ist so gerade jetzt wo es wieder
wärmer wird verschieben sich die
prioritäten normal und das kann man uns
bürgern auch gar nicht vorwerfen weil
wir gerade gemischte signale aus der
politik empfangen
irgendwelche kontakt beschränkungen
gelten bis irgendwann weiter aber viele
fitnessstudios haben wieder geöffnet
man sehnt sich nach normalität deswegen
sieht das meiste an den wochenenden bei
uns auch schon wieder erschreckend
normal aus erschrecken corona war da was
was ich toll finde
wir dürfen uns endlich wieder mit
mitgliedern aus anderen haushalten
treffen dürfen uns mit anderen familien
treffen höchste zeit sogar die deutsche
kneipe feiert ihr comeback und die
erleichterung im land ist geradezu mit
händen zu greifen so die zeit ja ja
warum
wenn man nur mit der frau zu hause so
die freunde finden das gemütliche
beisammensein weiß jeder oder
gemütliches beisammensein mit der
eigenen frau
das geht nicht jetzt aber zur besten
nachricht der woche ab dem 15 juni sind
alle grenzen zu unseren europäischen
nachbarn wieder auf finde ich gut
dieses europa war doch eigentlich eine
prima sache es könnten auch spaß mal
wieder versuchen und unseren
innenminister hier den kann eben nichts
mehr erschüttern denn was der mann schon
alles durchgemacht hat vielleicht zu den
politikern aktiven politikern die die
meisten gesundheits lebensmittel
rinderwahnsinn schweinepest vogelgrippe
gammelfleisch
verseuchte eier und ähnliches
durchgemacht haben verseuchte eier gibt
es da nicht was von ratiopharm
solange wir weiter abstand halten können
grenzen durchaus offen seinen sagen
zumindest experten jetzt müssen wir nur
noch die innerdeutschen grenzen
überwinden denn was gerade wo genau
erlaubt ist das kapiert ja wirklich
keiner mehr hallo freunde
es ist immens hier ja total peinlich
aber seine tolle corona tracing ist
immer noch nicht fertig weil ja warum
eigentlich nicht
hallo hallo dobel geschichte unser it
typ der jörg der hat wohl bier über den
router gekillt
ist aber auch egal dauert jedenfalls
noch jetzt aber die gute nachricht wir
haben eine viel coolere förder ramallah
die fundraising und spaß haben mit von
rassismus
sag mir wo hab ich fand trotz corona es
geht schon wieder viel mehr als du denn
ab sofort erlauben fußpflege in
mecklenburg vorpommern von köln nur 500
kilometer endlich nicht mehr selber
nägel lackieren direkt danach ab in die
proa metropole magdeburg in sachsen
anhalt dürfen sich wieder bis zum grün
kreuze treffen aber keine ahnung ist
alles selbst und sozusagen lehrers wo
halme sind ein meter fünfzig lag vor
verwirrung
[Musik]
der durch yus wieder auf extremo oder
toto dann ist auch kein leben und dann
schickt unsere von app mich zurück nach
köln
denn in nrw sind das ist kein witz thai
massagen wieder erlaubt ach so das
kontaktlose oder
das heißt ich muss mich selber passiert
und was ist mit der pnp auch selber
machen alles klar für die fundraising
jetzt schon einen runterladen
martin klempnow wichtig ist vor allem
eins wir müssen ab jetzt lokale
infektionsherde unter kontrolle behalten
irgendwie altenheime besser schützen
krankenhäuser aber übrigens auch
arbeitsmigranten aus osteuropa
spargelstecher erdbeerpflücker womit wir
beim zuständigkeitsbereich von julia
klöckner wäre ja für die krone
hygienemaßnahmen der erntehelfer ist in
deutschland mal der bauernverband
zuständig mal der landkreise mal das
gesundheitsamt wichtig sind
abstandsregelung geringe belegung bei
den unterkünften weitreichende
hygienemaßnahmen für die saison arbeiter
geht es nur vom spargelfeld zur
unterkunft kein abstand kaum mundschutz
nicht schön aber unsere spargel
versorgung ist gesichert
größtes problem bei den erntehelfern ist
allerdings die unterbringung viele leute
in einem zimmer in der theorie verboten
in der praxis gängige praxis freudscher
versprecher in 321 mit ausnahme von
familien gilt eine zimmerbelegung mit
maximal halber qualität nach kapazität
die halbe qualität war schon richtig
youtube gilt aber nicht nur für
erntehelfer sondern auch für die ost-
und südeuropäischen leiharbeiter die
unsere schlachthöfe am laufen halten
mittlerweile sind schon über 800 von
denen mit corona infiziert in mehreren
bundesländern wurden schlachthöfe
vorübergehend geschlossen ist wirklich
ein absolutes wurst case szenario was
wir erleben aber das exakte gegenteil
von einer überraschung wenn angela
merkel diese woche sagt uns erreichen
erschreckende nachrichten aus der
fleischindustrie kann ich nur sagen
nachrichten müssen schon neu sein
per definition die bundesregierung guckt
beim thema missbrauch von werkverträgen
und beim thema tricks beim mindestlohn
seit jahren weg und zwar absichtlich als
gefallen für diese branche die auch
jetzt wieder mit abwanderung droht
natürlich ihr bilder aus der unterkunft
der westfleisch arbeiter bei coesfeld da
hocken die zu zweit oder zu dritt in
winzigen angehimmelten putzen nächste
woche wie die groko angeblich ein
regelrechtes konzept vorlegen wie man
die zustände in der branche verbessern
könnte potzblitz aber auch jahrelang hat
das schicksal dieser menschen keine sau
gejuckt
aber jetzt wo es unsere infektionszahlen
betrifft macht mal auf für sowas hier
müssen wir uns alle gemeinsam schämen am
anfang waren wir zwei im zimmer doch
wenn sie keinen platz mehr hatten haben
sie die leute auch in der küche schlafen
lassen
zwölf leute insgesamt und in der küche 4
bis 5 die 270 euro miete pro person
haben sie uns direkt vom gehalt
abgezogen
ja ist doch total praktisch wer in der
küche pennt kriegt morgens den ersten
kaffee in den letzten jahren ist die
zahl der kontrollen in diesen betrieben
kontinuierlich zurückgegangen
das land niedersachsen hat gerade diese
woche zugegeben ihre schlachthöfe
zuletzt per telefon und per brief
kontrolliert zu haben
deswegen darf man als
nordrhein-westfälische arbeitsminister
auch nicht verblüfft tun dass das die
strukturen die insbesondere im bereich
der unterbringung von werkvertrags
arbeitnehmer teilweise vorherrschen
nicht den hygienebedingungen einer
pandemie entwicklung entsprechen könnten
nein wirklich könnte
seine eigene regierung hat erst vor
einem halben jahr bei 26 von 30
betrieben in nordrhein-westfalen zitat
gravierende arbeitsschutz mängel
festgestellt
deshalb gibt es hier demnächst ein
trommelwirbel beratungsangebot für
leiharbeiter die sich über ihre rechte
informieren möchten toll wirklich toll
tierwohl label ist das eine aber wir von
der heute-show fordern endlich eine
kennzeichnung auf jedem einzelnen
leiharbeiter können sie vom fleisch nada
steht auf der packung immer die
haltungsform 1 also stallhaltung ist die
schlechteste 4 ist die beste die
schweine den ganzen tag klassische musik
oder liegen auf yoga matten keine ahnung
könnte man doch auch für leiharbeiter
einführen natürlich die meisten werden
aktuell so gehalten da kriegt jeder
rumäne ungefähr die fläche eines
bierdeckels und alle husten sich
gegenseitig in den campingkocher das
wäre haltungsform 1 manchmal haben sie
sogar ein klo aber das kostet natürlich
mehr miete so logisch so und
haltungsform 4
das sind leiharbeiter die alle
überstunden bezahlt kriegen und ihre
mittagspause im firmen whirlpool
verbringen problem haltung
hier haben wir uns nur ausgedacht fast
alle leiharbeiter sind haltungsform 1
trotzdem guten appetit mit ihren
marinierten schweinenacken für 399
auch hier stellt sich einmal mehr die
frage was lernen wir eigentlich aus
gewohnt den preis für unser billiges
discounter fleisch zahlen leiharbeiter
aus osteuropa
wer spätestens jetzt mal zeit zum
umdenken
wir schalten live zu albrecht humboldt
er leitet den grill sportverein auf die
plätze fertig wurst in bergisch gladbach
herum bolt kann der deutsche griller
einfach so weitermachen
ja er selbstverständlich nicht ich bitte
sie wir stehen natürlich alle noch total
unter schock wegen coesfeld ist doch
klar
weil sich da so viele leiharbeiter
infiziert haben nein weil sie die
produktion da eingestellt haben für tage
tage lang wurde kein einziges schwein in
seine leckeren einzelteile zerlegt so
wie die natur es vorgesehen hat es ist
grillsaison was wir noch mehr betriebe
dicht machen soll ich mir hier eine
paprika dylan oder was da kann ich mir
auch gleich erschießen nein nein nein
nein ich schicke meine frau jetzt in
sämtliche discounter der umgebung
verkauft alles auf was noch nicht
zuständig tahir holzfäller sticks in
marinade haltbar bis 5
das wollten die ihren wegschmeißen alte
giller weisheit ist das stehen schon
voller maden musst du es in marinade
baden
das würde ich jetzt alles weg und dann
kandidaten das schön vektoren für den
sommer wir schlittern doch direkt
sehenden augen sind eine grill krise und
die merkel macht nichts dabei ist die
frau doch vom fach für die küche wurde
jede woche ein schwein geschlachtet und
und da habe ich auch mich immer daran
beteiligten wissen die wenigsten merkel
hat immer beim schlachten geholfen hat
die tiere meist mit der raute
naja wenn ihnen die schweine schon egal
sind was ist denn mit uns menschen
unsere industrielle nutztierhaltung ist
so was wie der perfekte nährboden für
krankheiten 60 prozent der neu
auftretenden infektionskrankheiten haben
einen tierischen ursprungs ist das alles
wurst nein das ist natürlich eine reale
gefahr
keine frage ich sag nur multiresistente
keime germanwatch hat mal nachgeguckt
auf welchem fleischmann die findet bei
netto in 58 prozent bei aldi in 75
prozent und bei penny in 82 prozent der
untersuchten fleischproben
antibiotikaresistente keime die sich auf
dem fleisch befinden können ein risiko
für uns darstellen denn bei der
zubereitung sehen wir sehr nicht
riesenproblem
ich sehe die biester jährlich wo sind
sie jedes jahr 33 1000 tote in europa
durch multiresistente keime auch weil
wir unsere reserve antibiotika in der
tiermast fun ballern ist ein totaler
wahnsinn ich sage
am ende werden wir uns entscheiden
müssen weiter billiges fleisch oder das
überleben der menschheit und das ist für
einen normalen deutschen ein
unauflösbarer konflikt ich weiß es
bringt mich um aber lecker albrecht
humboldt alter der club hatte er wieder
alles wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf also ich würde den
kanal direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt
mir drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]
a